il est celui qui aurait négocié l'accord
avec Kiev Kenny Prigogine Alexandre
lucachenko le président biélorus avait
assuré que le patron de Wagner était
dans son pays après la mutinerie du
groupe paramilitaire mais finalement
yves-gagny Prigogine serait toujours en
Russie je trouve que ça concernant
Prigogine il est à Saint-Pétersbourg
où est-il ce matin peut-être partir à
Moscou ou ailleurs
mais il n'est pas sur le territoire
biélorusse
selon le catchenko les combattants de
Wagner se trouvaient toujours dans leur
camp Vladimir Poutine leur avait
pourtant proposé de rejoindre l'armée
russe de retourner à la vie civile ou de
partir en Biélorussie difficile donc de
savoir si l'accord prévu avec qui est
gagné pregoji ne sera appliqué ou non
dans les prochains jours même si Moscou
assure que tout sera mis en place
la Russie ne suit pas les mouvements de
Prigogine l'accord passé le 24 juin est
toujours d'actualité
n'a plus donné de nouvelles depuis le 26
juin et ce message où il tentait de
justifier la rébellion depuis cette
tentative avortée les informations
tombent au compte-goutte sur le sort du
chef de la milice ces derniers jours
sont domicile a été perquisitionné et
les médias russes ont dévoilé quelques
photos de sa luxueuse maisons on y voit
des lingots d'or de nombreux armes mais
aussi plusieurs passeports et de
nombreuses perruques des médias russe
affirment qu'une photo avec des têtes
tranchées a été trouvées de quoi en
découvrir chaque jour un peu plus sur
celui qui a fait trembler le Kremlin et
dont l'avenir semble aujourd'hui
totalement incertain